العربيه ببدء اجتماع العقبه بين كبار
المسؤولين الامنيين والسياسيين
الاسرائيليين والفلسطينيين بمشاركه
امريكيه مصريه المباحثات ستشمل ملفات
سياسيه وامنيه وعسكريه وذلك بهدف وقف موجه
العنف التي اندلعت خلال العشر الاخيره
واضاف المسؤولون لروايتن الاجتماع سيعقد
ليوم واحد في ميناء العقبه على البحر
الاحمر بحضور مبعوث الرئيس الامريكي في
الشرق الاوسط
كما سيجتمع كبار قاده الامن الاسرائيليين
والفلسطينيين للمره الاولى منذ عده سنوات
بالاضافه الى ممثلين عن اطراف سياسيه بل
اطراف الرئيسيه في المنطقه في المقابل
المشاهدين استنكرت فصائر فلسطينيه مشاركه
وفد من السلطه في الاجتماع قالت انه
استكمالا لما وصفته بمخططات التامر على
الشعب
هذا وكشف تقرير صحفي اسرائيلي ان رئيس
جهاز الامن العام شباك سيشارك في القمه
الامنيه المقرر انطلاقها في العقبه
بالاردن وقال موقع ووالا انبار سينضم
للوفد الاسرائيلي المكون من مستشار الامن
القومي صحيحانجبي ومدير عام وزاره
الخارجيه
الحكومي في المناطق الفلسطينيه اللواء
الاسرائيلي غسان عليان ان مشاركه البار
تدل على الاهميه التي يليها الشابات لوقف
التصعيد الامني في الضفه الغربيه حتى لا
يتحول الى انتفاضه جديده
من القسم مشاهدينا ينضم الينا مراسل
العربيه زياد حلبي اهلا بك زياد وباي عين
يراقب الفلسطينيون والاسرائيليون اجتماع
العقبه اليوم
في الاراضي الفلسطينيه لا يريدون رؤيه هذا
الاجتماع شعبيا اقصد هناك نوع من الغضب
والرفض لهذا الاجتماع كونه ياتي بعد
يصفونها بمجزره نابلس التي قتلت فيها
اسرائيل احد عشر فلسطينيين واصابت اكثر من
مئه على الجانب الاسرائيلي لا مبالاه
تقريبا شعبيا لان اسرائيل غارقه في امور
اخرى تماما مثل الانقلاب على القضاء
والمظاهرات وهذا جل ما يهتم به الاعلام في
اسرائيل لكن بين هذا وذاك علينا ان نقول
بان هذه القمه لم يخطط لها بعد ما حدث في
نابلس وان قبل ذلك عندما كان بلينكن هنا
في المنطقه اتفق مع الطرفين على ضروره عقد
هذه القمه في العقبه في محاوله للنجم
الاستيطان الاسرائيلي في مقابل نوع من
اداء للسلطه الفلسطينيه في شمال الضفه
المحتله حيث لا سيطر في نابلس وجنين لا
للسلطه ولا لاسرائيل في مقابل يعني مقايضه
وقف التوسع الاستيطاني بهذا الامر وجاء
طبعا ذلك ايضا قبل
الاجتماع مجلس الامن الذي دانه الاستيطان
عندها وضعت اللمسات الاخيره على هذه القمه
عمليا طيب زياد بالتوازي مع رفض فصائل
فلسطينيه لعقد هذا الاجتماع هل هناك ايضا
اطراف في الداخل الاسرائيلي ترفض ايضا عقد
هذا الاجتماع وخاصه مع ارتفاع شعبيه اقصى
اليمين بحسب بعض الاستطلاعات في اسرائيل
من بعض الفئات داخل المجتمع الاسرائيلي
هذا صحيح جدا اليمين في اسرائيل محرج
تماما لا يريد اي اتصال علني مع اركان في
السلطه الفلسطينيه خاصه ان هناك يعني
الوزير حسين الشيخ يشارك
في هذا الاجتماع ومستشار الامن القومي
الاسرائيلي لا يريدون هذه الاجتماعات
العلنيه والاتصالات مع السلطه الفلسطينيه
لان لها طابع بالاضافه الى الامن لها غلاف
سياسي وهذا ما لا يريده اليمين في اسرائيل
طبعا هذا يذكر الكثيرين ممن عايشوا هذا
الصراع في السنوات الاخيره في قمه العقب
عام 2003 التي كانت في خضم الانتفاضه
الفلسطينيه الثانيه كانت محاوله ايضا طبعا
على مستوى اعلى اعلى من هذا المستوى شارك
الرئيس الامريكي رئيس وزراء اسرائيل الملك
الاردني ورئيس الوزراء الفلسطيني محمود
عباس لان ياسر عرفات كان محاصرا في
المقاطعه لم تنجح تلك القمه وحاليا في هذه
القمه هناك سؤال كبير حول النتيجه لانه
عمليا حتى لو السلطه الفلسطينيه حاولت ان
تقوم باجراءات امنيه على الارض هناك امر
لا يخضع لمن يجتمعون في هذه القمه على
الارض وهو العمليات الفرديه يعني فتى في
الخامسه عشره يستطيع ان ينفذ عمليه وان ان
يقود ذلك الى نوع من التصعيد بغض النظر
عما سيناقشه المجتمعون في العقبه وبالتالي
الامور مركبه اكثر بكثير من مجرد اجتماع
لاحتواء الامر حاليا
في اسرائيل طبعا الشباك الاسرائيلي قلق
جدا مما يحدث لان التوقعات الاسرائيليه ان
استمرت المواجهه على هذا المنوال بمعنى
اقتحامات اسرائيليه وحصيله كبيره من
الضحايا بين الفلسطينيين وصولا الى شهر
رمضان قد يقود الامر الى حرب شامله
انتفاضه في الضفه وحرب في قطاع غزه السؤال
ليس ما يحدث في العقبه السؤال هو هل
يستطيع نتنياهو ان يمنع وزير الامن
الاسرائيلي الداخلي بن جبير من اقتحام
الاقصى في رمضان هذا هو السؤال ربما الذي
يقول ان كانت تصعيد سيتم ام سيتم باحتواء
شكرا لكم معنا مراسل العربيه زياد حلبي
ومن عمان مشاهدينا ينضموا الينا مراسله
العربيه عماد عضايله اهلا بك عماد هل يحمل
هذا الاجتماع طابعا امنيا خالصا ام سياسيا
ايضا بالنظر الى طبيعه الوفود المشارك
المشاركه
ومستوى التمثيل ايضا
نعم احمد هو اجتماع امني سياسي بحسب يعني
حسب الحضور في هذا الاجتماع من مدراء
الاجهزه الامنيه بالاضافه الى وزراء
الخارجيه وايضا يعني المستشارين السياسيين
للزعماء هذا هذه الاجتماعات يعني لها
اهميه كبيره ويولي بها المجتمع الدولي
يولي هناك اهتمام كبير بهذه الاجتماعات
لسببين السبب الاول هو التصعيد في الاراضي
الفلسطينيه والوصول لهذا لتهدئه هذه هذا
التصعيد والتوتر في الاراضي الفلسطينيه
اضافه الى ذلك التوقيت الذي يعني حدث او
حصل به هذا الاجتماع وهو ما قبل رمضان حيث
دائما يعني تحدث التوترات في الاراضي
الفلسطينيه بشكل اكبر واوسع في شهر رمضان
والتزامن مع الاعياد اليهوديه اضافه الى
ذلك ان هذا الاجتماع بعد انقطاع طويل ما
بين المفاوضات الاسرائيليه
الفلسطينيه لذلك هذا الاجتماع يعني له
اهميه كبيره جدا في المجتمع الدولي الاردن
نجحت باستضافه هذا الاجتماع وجمع الاطراف
على طاوله واحده واحده لاعاده يعني
التفاوض واعاده يعني يعني او للوصول الى
تفاهمات وايضا احس اسرائيل
الالتزام بالقرارات الدوليه والقرارات
الشرعيه وحل الدولتين حل الدوله
وبناء على يعني دوله فلسطينيه
موحده بالاضافه الى يعني تنفيذ القرارات
الدوليه
لمصلحه الطرفين من المعروف ان يعني في شهر
رمضان تبدا اسرائيل باقتحامات للمسجد
الاقصى وايضا يعني
تهديد لبعض المدن ويكون هناك يعني توتر
عالي جدا لذلك هذه الاجتماعات وعند هذه
النقطه
الفلسطينيه
على ضمانات من خلال هذا الاجتماع
وقف تجاوزات اسرائيل ام ان دعنا نقول هل
هناك ايضا طرف يعول عليه وهو قادر ايضا
على تقديم هذه الضمانات
[موسيقى]
الضغط على اسرائيل يعني عدم او لوقف هذه
الممارسات التي من شانها تصعيد التوتر
داخل الاراضي الفلسطينيه والتحذير ايضا من
انتفاضه قادمه في يعني في شهر رمضان طيب
عماد يعني هل ماذا عن دول زمني لهذا
الاجتماع هل سيكتفى بيوم واحد اما ان هناك
احتماليه لتمديد هذا الاجتماع ليوم اخر
حسب المصادر الاجتماع بدا قبل ساعه ونصف
من الان الساعه العاشره بتوقيت عمان
وينتهي الساعه الخامسه ايضا سيكون هناك
يعني تصريحات ربما تصريحات صحفيه بالاضافه
سيكون هناك بيان من
سيخرج من هذا الاجتماع يعني توضيح كافه
المجريات ومجريات هذا الاجتماع واللقاء
وماذا توصل الفلسطيني والاسرائيليين حول
كافه القضايا وحول تهدئه الاوضاع في
الاراضي الفلسطينيه قبل كما تحدثنا قبل
رمضان ونشدد هنا في رمضان لان الاوضاع
تتوتر بشكل اكبر في رمضان لان يعني المسجد
الاقصى يامه الاف الالاف من المصلين ويكون
هناك اجراءات استفزازيه من من
الاسرائيليين لذلك يعني هذه الاجتماعات
لها اهميه كبيره جدا يعول عليها لتهدئه
الاوضاع في الاراضي الفلسطينيه ولوقف
اسرائيل شافت الاجراءات منها الاجراءات
الاحاديه الجانب بالاضافه الى الاقتحامات
ويعني منع المصلين الفلسطينيين من الصلاه
في المسجد الاقصى
هذا الاجتماع شكرا لك من عمان كنت معنا
مراسل العربيه عماد العضله تحيه عماد